okay I'm going to talk to you about the
double circulatory system the double
circulatory system is how we pump blood
to every single cell in the body in
order to deliver glucose and oxygen for
the process of aerobic respiration so it
can release energy and also remove all
the waste products like urea and carbon
dioxide so one of the most important
organs that we have is our heart and I'm
going to draw a real simple diagram of
it right now so really simply put the
heart has four different chambers okay
the atria are above and the ventricles
are below I always remember the atria or
atrium if there's one of them atrium
starts with a and sodas above so
remember that these are above now this
one here is the left atrium now this
looks confusing because it appears to be
on the right hand side the way that we
remember this is because in science
that's what everyone oh we're looking at
something in anatomy it's like it's
looking straight at us
so as a result this is the left hand
side and this is the right hand side so
what we're going to do is we're going to
see how blood passes through the heart
and round the body so first of all the
left-hand side of the heart is involved
in pumping oxygenated blood oxygenated
blood to the body so this is just blood
which contains oxygen and we want to
deliver it to cells so they get that
oxygen so they could use it for
respiration so this starts here in the
left ventricle
now the left ventricle has a really
really thick wall now the reason that
has such a thick wall is that we need to
pump this blood with a lot of pressure
think about if you put your hands up in
the air we need to get all of that blood
right to your fingers even though we're
pumping it against gravity so as a
result this left ventricle wall has to
be extremely extremely thick so all of
this blood passes out through this
vessel here which is the
biggest vessel in our body it's an
artery called the aorta the aortic also
starts with an A so does the word artery
that's the way we can remember another
nice thing is arteries begins with an A
and they carry blood away from the heart
so arteries always carry blood away from
the heart
so this oxygenated blood travels from
the left ventricle through this a water
through the rest of the body now and the
rest of the body we use up that oxygen
in the cells now when it comes back the
blood comes back into the heart it is
now deoxygenated this means it does not
contain oxygen deoxygenated does not
contain oxygen so this blood now appears
blue so it enters the heart in a vessel
called the vena cava book the vena cava
again the vena verse vein the vena cava
is a vein and the nice way of
remembering what veins do is they take
blood in to the heart so arteries a away
veins take blood in now this particular
part of the heart here contains the
oxygenated blood and it's called the
right atrium
remember atrium atria are above a 488 a
4 above the ventricles okay now to get
from the right atrium to the right
ventricle we need to go through this
structure called a valve and all of
valve is is something that allows the
blood to keep flowing in the same
direction so let's think about where we
want to pop this blood now at the moment
this blood is deoxygenated which means
it does not contain oxygen so what we
want to do is we want to pump this to
the lungs in order to pick up oxygen
so that's what happens this is the right
ventricle now the right ventricle also
has a wall that contracts and is going
to pump this blood through this vessel
here to the lungs
now this vessel here is called the
pulmonary artery so a lot of people get
confused with all of these different
terms so let's think about how we can
remember this whenever we see the word
pulmonary it's to do with the lungs
pulmonary City with the lungs and artery
think of a for a way so the pulmonary
artery can take deoxygenated blood to
the lungs just try and think about it
each time if it's be oxygenated where do
we need to send it we need to send it to
the lungs to pick up oxygen so that's
the pulmonary artery so once that blood
has been to the lungs it kicks up loads
of that oxygen and it comes back into
the heart it comes back into the heart
because it's ready to be pumped around
to the rest of the body so it enters via
this vessel here which is called is to
do with the lungs so it's called
pulmonary and it's taking blood into the
heart so it's a pulmonary vein taking
blood in so we can see that this will
want to remain takes blood into the left
atrium and then the final step that we
need to say see just like on the right
hand side oops just like on the right
hand side we have a valve so for blood
to come from the left atrium to the left
ventricle it just needs to travel
through this particular valve so that is
the double circulatory system thank you
very much